hello everyone Karen warden with phone
Kurds radio show were outside the studio
with our wonderful co host for today's
show with peter shankman actor producer
writer wesley a and West's has been a
friend of ours for many years and he's
been talking to us about how he's wanted
to do his own project for a long time
and he finally did that with a movie
called Night Dream blues and because you
had talked about this for so long what
was it that kind of finally gave you the
kick in the pants to do it and how did
you find the discipline it's so easy to
like be in LA and then you get
distracted by a million things where did
you home that discipline weird you on
that time I think in a lot of ways um
you know through the process of making
this project happen I've really come to
believe that things will happen the way
they're supposed to happen and you can
sort of have your own ideas about how
it's going to happen and you can try to
fit that square peg in a round hole but
in a lot of ways it's going to happen to
its supposed to happen my meaning is
that I started the project i started
thinking about the idea about two and a
half years ago and i started writing it
and you know went through series of
changes in terms of drafts in terms of
people being attached to the project and
then i kind of like a lost steam I lost
sort of faith in a project and I got
distracted like you said bye bye other
projects and I went away and then I
don't know if for whatever reason I come
back to it and I've been focused driving
I was thinking about the project I
should go back and do another draft and
then I went back and did another draft
and I got immediately excited about it
and then just so happens at that time I
was speaking to
an actor friend of mine who had come off
producing a project and I sort of you
know spoke to him about this other
project and then several weeks later I'm
you know ran into a director friend and
I sort of got her interest in your
project and and then it's sort of like
became this whole other animal that I
don't think it could have been a year
and a half two years ago you know um so
I think in a lot of ways you know and I
sort of compare this to like the
discipline of writing sometimes the best
thing to do is to walk away from the
computer or that scene or that character
often so that's what I have to do I
wrote and wrote it I wrote it and I
believe in it and then for whatever
reason I just organically had to walk
away you know I I had gone through
series of readings and met several
people and then it's somehow lost steam
I lost interest in it and I just walked
away and I didn't think about gosh I
need to get back to it I just I just
knew that there was a good story there
and at some point it would come out and
so walked away and then probably like
eight eight and a half months later it's
sort of like came back to me in my head
and I started figuring things out I went
back to the computer and then it's sort
of like I had this new engine in
in the product and so I think throughout
the entire course of getting this film
produced and shot I really have come to
believe that that whatever we do as
artists sometimes we just have to like
no one to walk away and no one to like
let it breathe and and if it's a good
product if it's a good story that's a
good project it'll it'll happen on its
own it'll happen with the people that
you may not have imagined that it'll
happen with the right people so yeah so
you're not about forcing things because
I think Stephen King had also talked
about that too like writing scripts and
then putting them in a drawer for a
short time to kind of give them some
space yeah and then come back to it
fresh it sounds like then you're not
about forcing the issue because I know
we spoke to a guide in KU who has no
film school calm and also the
kickstarter campaign for a man-child and
he was telling us how he clocks his time
to do a full eight hours and i just
thought that was great and I know as
someone who's struggled with their own
discipline do you find that you have to
rein yourself in sometimes or do you
like more freedom and you think that the
freedom is good because that enables you
to become more creative and ah I
thinking discipline is really important
because when I was writing I was
actively writing every single day you
know I was sitting in front of the
computer and I was working out scenes
and and and if there's a problem in my
head about the story about the
characters or what I've seen I would try
to work it out um I do believe that
nothing happened like you know I spoke
with a friend of mine who's like some
you know like has a PhD in science and
ask for physics whatever in and she was
telling you this idea that the only law
than governments two universes cause and
effect you know is that is that
something happens and there's always an
effect you know and and so science is
always trying to study the cause and
effect and so I really come to believe
that everything happens because
something else happened I've made a
phone call to someone and now that
person has called me back and what if
that person doesn't call me back that
person at least knows that I call them
and so throughout the entire process of
writing this movie I really tried to
hold on to the idea that if I don't
write it it's not going to get written
and if I don't solve this problem it's
not going to get solved and I don't talk
to this director about potentially
directing this movie or that actor about
possibly auditioning or that producer
about possibly investing it's not going
to get done and so sometimes you have to
like you have to like ask for the
business you know you have to ask for
the for the investment or or whatever
and so I think discipline is really
really important i don't believe in the
idea that you could just sort of like
wake up and be like and just walk away i
think you have to be disciplined I mean
part of that discipline is knowing when
to let it breathe knowing when to sort
of like you know I never wrote on the
weekends ever um I believe that you have
to give yourself space to walk away and
so I would wake up at eight-thirty every
single morning and I would have my cup
of coffee and I would write write write
and then I would go and have lunch with
a friend come back and I would have an
audition or whatever know right and then
at some point after dinner I would be
like I'm going to go watch a movie or
I'm gonna go read or whatever and then
when weekends come I'm out having fun
and do another thing
work or you know doing a play or
whatever because I think that I think
for me and I don't know how other people
work but for me I have to have that
balance I have to be like saying in my
head to be able to attack a problem you
know I can't I can't be desperate you
know and what about discipline i do you
think that there's a cause and effect
and so if you want an effect you had to
cause it you know and and so that was my
entire process was you know I made a lot
of phone calls to people and I spoke
with a lot of directors about this movie
and I had to make pitches and I had to
you know I think you guys were the
people who really threw our friendship
really suggested that UV that like hey
West you should really get on
Kickstarter and for a while crowd
funding was like I was like I'm not
going to go beg for money you know like
what is this I'm gonna go get from real
investors and I think I heard about
crowdfunding with you guys and I saw so
you know a mutual friend Bryan Derr can
do do his thing and and I was like wow I
really really want to try to do this and
what else you gonna do right so we
talked about it with some of our other
producers about crowdfunding and they
initially felt the same way they're like
let's try to get real money from real
investors and at some point we were all
like a for a project with with our
budget you know $100 $100 you know you
can't be kept showing that so I you know
we and that was that was a clear example
of cause and effect we had to you know
shoot a mock trailer we I had to write
the literature for it we had to start an
account and then we had to like launch
it and then we had to like tell people
about it and then meet there was you
know effect because we raised in our
first weekend we raised like fifteen
hundred dollars in a first weekend and
then it dipped immediately but the first
weekend we were like oh my god like I
think a third investor donated two
hundred and fifty dollars and he's like
a fellow actor friend
but that's an example of cause and
effect you know and that I think is
really really sort of universal in that
we haven't sort of like do
Oh